عام 2019 تحولت الشائعات الى حقيقه تم
الاتفاق على نقل رونالدو الى ريال مدريد
مقابل مبلغ كليا قدره 80 مليون جنيه
استرليني ليصبح حينها اغلى لاعبا تم شرائه
في تاريخ كره القدم تصدر الانتقال
العناوين في العالم وبدا رونالدو سعيدا
ومتحمسا لللعب مع الفريق الحاصل على 31
لقبا للدوري الاسباني واحد اثنان
مرحبا مدريد
بينما يقدم رونالدو افضل اداء بحسب قدراته
وفي جعبته اكثر من 33 هدفا في الموسم
انتهى اول موسم له دون احراز اي كاس ولا
كره ذهبيه ولا كاس الدوري الاسباني ولا
كاس دوري ابطال اوروبا اذ خسر الكؤوس
الثلاثه امام برشلونه وولدهم الذهبي ميسي
لكن بدخول موسم 2010 2011 عاد رونالدو الى
عادته في الفوز بجائزه الكره الذهبيه والى
ارتداء القميص ذي الرقم 7 بعد مغادره
راؤول في نهايه الموسم المنصرم شعر
رونالدو بان ريال مدريد بيته الجديد
وساعده ذلك الانتقال على تطوير مهاراته في
جوانب اللعبه كافه
استعد دوما بالطريقه نفسها لا يهمني ضد اي
فريق سالعب يبقى تركيزي هو نفسه
ربما حين العب ضد اكبر الفرق تكون الحماسه
لدي اعلى قليلا لكن الامر سيان اركز
ذهنيا دوما على تقديم افضل ما لدي لم يكن
يتطور فقط من ناحيه مهاراته بل بدا موقفه
خلال المباريات يتغير ايضا قد يفعل
رونالدو في
سن قد تب
دو لكنه نال بطاقات حمراء وتسبب في عثرات
لم تبدو ضروريه احيانا لكن حين صار يقود
ريال مدريد ومنتخب البرتغال تحمل
المسؤوليه المرافقه لذلك ليس فقط واحدا من
اروع لاعبي كره القدم في العالم ربما هو
اعظم لاعب انه مثل روجيه فيديرير واحد من
اعظم رياضي العالم ينظر الناس حول العالم
اليه باعجاب سواء اكان من محبي كره القدم
ام لا وهو معروف في ارجاء العالم ويحمل
كريستيانو رونالدو ذلك بكل تاكيد لست قلقا
لان هذا يحدث بالعاده لن اتكلم عن تجاوزات
برشلونه ولا المهمات المستحيله لان الامر
لا يهمني ما يهم الان ان لدينا مباراه غدا
وان ربحنا
فسنستمر وان خسرنا فسنعود للمنزل انا
متفائل اننا سنربح المباراه وسنربحها
بالتاكيد